hard and this building is the the most
advanced car factory that earth has ever
seen earlier this year during the launch
of its new gigafactory giga texas elon
finally announced that the new austin
plant will start building the cyber
truck in 2023 seeing as the cyber truck
has faced many challenges in its
productions
oh my god
installing it for over two years what
makes this new multi-billion dollar
cyber truck gigafactory the perfect
product for building the ultra
futuristic vehicle let's find out the
new gigafactory the buildings were all
separate there's a lot of movement
between the buildings um and uh
the the thing that we thought makes
sense is to really think of it like like
a chip like an integrated circuit uh
combining everything together in one
package
and
now
this is what you get
gigatexas is located just outside of
austin texas and it's tesla's largest
factory yet during the launch event on
april 7th elon proudly strutted out in
front of a cyber truck along with his
design chief franz von holzhausen and
said it's been an intense couple of
years but we're going to have this for
you next year and it's going to be great
it's been it's been an intense couple
years uh
but we're gonna have this for you next
year and you're gonna it's gonna be
great the two men seem to consider the
idea of smashing its window with a
hammer as they famously did it the
original reveal of the cyber truck in
2019 but then chose to reject it as the
crowd applauded
i didn't bring my hammer this time
the gigatexas site covers an area of
about 3 million square feet which is
equivalent to about 60 football fields
with this new addition tesla now has a
total of six factories across the globe
giga texas is designed to be one of the
world's biggest factories not only
because tesla wants high volume
production at the plant but also because
they want the factory to be vertically
integrated down to battery cell
production on site according to elon he
has considered his gigafactories as the
primary product of tesla the cars are
just the byproduct of the process thus
gigatexas is the most optimized auto
manufacturing factory in the world no
automaker even comes close to it tesla
and elon have revolutionized the
production line of cars with their
gigafactories already but they have
taken the vertical integration to the
next level in gigatexas all the various
shops are arranged so that production
actually takes place right in motion
along the assembly line from the supply
of materials for production on one side
of the factory to the departure of the
finished car on the other side thus it
saves not only the precious time spent
on production but also the land on which
the factory can build the current
manufacturing building occupies space
equivalent to about 15 city blocks and
if you were to stand the building on its
side it would be taller than the burj
khalifa by over 300 meters no wonder
elon claims it is the world's largest
factory building by volume
it's taller than the burj khalifa
uh that's to scale
it's 80 feet tall
it's
equivalent to three pentagons the
factory can produce up to 500 000
vehicles per year when fully operational
in addition to the cyber truck gigatexas
will also build tesla's new semi truck
and the model y suv as of the recording
of this video significant parts of the
factory are still under construction but
tesla has already started the production
of around 150 model wise per day the
foundations for the giant new giga
presses developed by idra group and
required for casting cybertruck chassis
components have already been late it's
expected to be operational by the end of
this year i've made a whole video on
them and i'll link it in the description
if you'd like to check that out what's
more gigatexas is designed to be as
sustainable as possible it will recycle
water to reduce its impact on the local
water supply like all of tesla's other
gigafactories this one will also have a
solar roof installed on top of the
building to offset some of the
electricity used by the factory tesla
also says that the factory will have a
zero waste policy meaning that all of
the waste produced will be recycled or
reused and there are even plans that the
factory will generate its own food using
an on-site farm as if all these were not
enough within a couple of months of
inaugurating the new factory tesla has
already filed with the city of austin to
expand gigatexas further with an
additional 500 000 square foot building
at the site plus the factory is rumored
to have already created more than 5 000
jobs in the austin area and will add a
few more thousand in the coming years
with all this development work the stage
is set and it seems like tesla is well
on its way to start churning out the
cyber truck within the timeline
announced by elon for once so let's have
a refresher on the much anticipated
vehicle and remind ourselves of the
capabilities of this new truck the cyber
truck okay let's talk about the cyber
truck tesla first unveiled the
all-electric pickup truck in november of
2019 and it quickly became one of the
most talked about vehicles in years the
design is certainly unique and it's
unlike anything else on the road its
unconventional boxy design had me
confused the first time i saw it i
remember thinking were elon and tesla
playing a joke on us but as it turns out
the truck is designed keeping
aerodynamics in mind its interesting
design surprised many engineers in the
first independent aerodynamics
performance simulation test it comes in
at an unofficial 0.39 drag coefficient
most pickup truck designs have extremely
inefficient aerodynamic designs and
generally have a bad drag coefficient
between 0.55 and 0.65 so cybertruck's
novel design has some serious
aerodynamic benefits no doubt making the
car more energy efficient the truck's
exterior will be made out of a stainless
steel body the high quality 300 series
stainless steel alloy that'll be used
for the construction will be corrosion
resistant strong and affordable that's
why the tesla cybertruck team chose a
stainless steel alloy to create the
cybertruck exoskeleton this steel alloy
will be known as the ultra hard 30x cold
rolled stainless steel while the blend
is proprietary elon mentioned during the
product launch that the exoskeleton
material of the vehicle is the same as
the spacex starship shell there have
also been recent reports that tesla
plans to use one steel supplier in the
future steel dynamics which operates a
factory in texas the facility recently
underwent an upgrade worth some 1.7
billion dollars probably in preparation
to support the cyber trucks production
demands on top of all this the factory
is only a few hours away from the giga
texas plant which will further
streamline the process elon has made a
lot of fuss about the nearly
indestructible body and windows during
the launch event in 2019. it is expected
that due to this all steel construction
the cyber truck will be more resistant
to nicks and dents plus the window glass
is actually bulletproof having been
tested to withstand a nine millimeter
handgun round now that seems a bit
excessive to me but then again when is
tesla shied away from doing the
unthinkable so what can we expect from
the production version of the cyber
truck now that we know giga texas will
be the base of production well according
to elon it will be very similar to the
prototype that was unveiled back in 2019
however there may be some slight changes
to the design such as adding side
mirrors and making the headlights look
less like a cyborg when the ev was
originally unveiled elon also mentioned
that the exterior would see some
redesign including removing the door
handles although it was never clear how
that would work the truck will seat six
people and is equipped with a 6.5 foot
bed called the cybertrucks vault the top
is covered but it unrolls if you need to
fit in something higher than the vault's
route this will offer 100 cubic feet of
lockable exterior storage outside of the
truck the interior will be sparse and
minimalistic as per tesla's design
philosophy but offer additional storage
under the second row seats and will
feature a 17-inch touchscreen it will
also feature onboard power and
compressed air for activities like
camping the truck can raise or lower the
suspension by 4 inches and comes with 3
500 pounds of payload capacity as for
the specs the cyber truck will be
available in three different versions
the single motor dual motor and
tri-motor variant they'll be able to do
0 to 60 in 6.5 seconds 4.5 seconds and
2.9 seconds respectively the single
motor rear wheel drive version will
offer 250 plus miles of range a dual
motor all-wheel drive version or awd
will reach 300 plus miles of range and a
tri-motor all-wheel drive version will
have 500 plus miles of range however in
a recent patent filing from tesla for
its cybertruck ui system all the sample
photos show an available range of 610
miles hinting at a potentially larger
range on the ev although tesla has not
confirmed this it is not unreasonable to
believe that it may be achievable on the
tri-motor option all truck versions will
come standard with all-wheel drive and
tesla's new cyberquad four-wheel
steering system and like the model s the
cyber truck will also have an air
suspension system that can automatically
adjust the ride height based on the
driving conditions as for the price the
single motor version will start at
thirty nine thousand nine hundred
dollars while the dual motor and tri
motor will cost forty nine thousand nine
hundred dollars and sixty nine thousand
nine hundred dollars respectively tesla
is also taking reservations for the
truck with a 100 deposit furthermore
tesla has begun introducing a v10 beta
version of its full self-driving
capabilities cybertruck customers can
currently add the fsd feature for an
additional ten thousand dollars as of
may 2021 reservations had surpassed 1
million and continued to grow even as
deliveries looked less likely to begin
before the year's end recent unofficial
reservation trackers have put the
pre-orders to over 1.25 million trucks
pre-ordered that should give you an idea
of the popularity of the vehicle
according to the same report most
pre-orders choose the dual motor and
tri-motor versions only an estimated 17
of the pre-orders are for the single
motor model which is the one supposed to
be available first so to wrap things up
the production of the cyber truck is set
to begin in 2023 and customers should
start seeing the delivery from the
second quarter of the year so if you are
one of those who have pre-ordered one
you'll most likely have to wait over a
year to get your hands on one but in the
meantime you can keep dreaming about
what it would be like to drive this
stainless steel beast of a pickup truck
what do you think will tesla be able to
stick to its delivery time frame for the
cybertruck or will we see more delays
despite the fact that gigatexas is
almost fully operational and when do you
expect the cyber truck to hit the road
let us know in the comment section below
if you enjoyed this video subscribe to
the channel and hit the notification
bell so that you are updated the minute
we release another video see you at the
next one